Billy you're making history with this
movie and it was almost an entirely
lgbtq plus cast and crew so how does it
feel now that the movie is closer to
being released are you I bet there's a
little bit of nerves involved of course
I mean you'd be crazy not to be nervous
but yeah you know we all love the movie
so much uh it's very rare almost the
entire cast is all openly lgbtq
character actors even playing the
straight characters which very rarely
happens although except for some
celebrity cameos thank you yeah
um we do have some very fun celebrity
cameos Deborah Messing from Will and
Grace
absolutely hilarious in this and Russia
Kristen Chenoweth and a bunch of others
I don't want to give it away but yeah it
was it was very special and you know but
a comedy is a comedy you know it was
produced by Judd Apatow who's made some
of the funniest comedies ever
bridesmaids and 40 year old virgin and
knocked up and train wrecked and Nick
Stoler directed and he made for getting
Sarah Marshall but we've never had a
movie like that like a big you know
Studio comedy about gay couples and so
that's what this is but you know if
you're if you like comedy you're gonna
like it whether you're straight gay or
no matter what you are yeah yeah it's
just funny funny is funny so wait so
this was Luke this was your first time
auditioning for a studio film right it
was my first time auditioning for a lead
in a studio film okay a lead in the
studio yes yes it went well it went well
I'm still pinching myself
um yeah it's great it's nerve-wracking I
think you know as an actor you you
always want to do the big movies but
they seem so hard to get you know the
truth is it's a very competitive
business as it turns out um so yeah I'm
lucky it went well and I'm lucky that a
part came along that just made so much
sense for me to inhabit but speaking of
parts of you also you
unlike homework homework yes Hallmark
has been very good to me and I really
enjoy working with Hallmark and um yeah
I've made about 13 Hallmark movies a lot
of Christmas movies yeah
regardless but what how what's y'all's
take on people like on representation
you know what I'm saying so if people
are gay playing a straight person or
straight playing a gay person what's
your take on it well I just saw this
morning Hallmark is doing a Hanukkah
movie this year and I wasn't called and
I'm furious you know you know I am
writing a Stern letter yeah please
please write to them okay you know look
I mean acting is an art form you know
you know it's not like oh gay can only
play gay and straight can only play
straight yeah um but you know
historically most of the high profile
lgbtq roles we've seen in movies those
roles are often played by Straight movie
stars and some of them have been amazing
you know of course they've been
magnificent but we would like an
opportunity to start movies too you know
we've never really gotten that
especially in a big funny comedy like
this and so we're just trying to you
know correct that imbalance a little bit
and give new people an opportunity to
shine yeah
I agree with that yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
yeah
[Music]